merci de nous rejoindre sur téléfilm
nous allons parler de sport nouvelle
édition du 7 8 sport 26 minutes pour
faire le tour de l'actualité sportive
dans le département sur saint quentin
sur versailles plus particulièrement bon
soir anthony on sort wilfried au menu de
ce sept huit sports tout d'abord du
rugby avec la 5e édition du tournoi
international organisé par le sky rugby
ce week-end et olivier laval le
responsable événements du club sera avec
nous sur ce plateau pour en parler je
recevrai également patrick guérin
professeur de commerce et de marketing
au lycée saint-vincent-de-paul de
versailles il court désormais en
fonction de l'argent récolté par ses
élèves dans le cadre d'un projet
pédagogique et puis comme d'habitude
wilfried en fin d'émission tous les
résultats du week-end et tous les
résultats et je le disais alors on va
commencer par des rugbys on va
s'intéresser au rugby avec plaisir qui
ça y est c'est officiel va jouer en
playoffs pour la deuxième année
consécutive exactement après une saison
assez haletante avons ce week-end et la
17e journée de fédérale 3 plaisir et est
en bonne position pour se qualifier pour
ces playoffs
restait à confirmer ce week-end en
s'imposant à domicile face à l'union des
bords de marne l'objectif est atteint
mais non sans embûches
au cours de ce match d'ailleurs ce récit
d'un match décisif avec julie rochas
waris au stade robert barran l'entamé de
match et plaisir oise après une pénalité
transformée dès la première minute de
jeu le demi de mêlée saint quentinois
jour rapidement ce coup franc à cinq
mètres de la ligne d'en-but marne et le
coup de malice et transformé 10 3 après
six minutes de jeu dans cette première
période les joueurs de philippe behar
sont bien aidé par la maladresse des
visiteurs et surtout par ce mauvais
geste synonyme de carton jaune
en supériorité numérique les bleus et
jaunes récitent leur rugby basé sur une
conquête solide et des lancements de jeu
tout feu tout flamme sur cette déviation
en touche
françois le vilain file sous les poteaux
pour retour des vestiaires changement de
registre les plaisirs wa deviennent
fébrile il recule à l'impact
les espaces se créent c'est tout le
stade robert barran qui se met à douter
il n'en fallait pas plus aux visiteurs
pour inscrire deux essais et revenir à
quatre longueurs à cinq minutes du coup
de sifflet final plaisir ne mène plus
que 20 16 on se dit alors que le prc va
laisser échapper le match jusqu'à ce
maul pénétrant des gros à la dernière
action de jeu
victoire à l'arraché 25-16 les plaisirs
oies se qualifie pour les playoff pour
la deuxième saison consécutive mais non
sans frayeur c'est un essai c'est pas en
france et moi qui marque mais on sent un
essai collectif coincer les gros c'est
une action c'est là son collectif qui
était assez importante parce que à la
fin du match et commence à se resserrer
ça devenait dix ans on a fait une
deuxième mi temps qui n'était pas de ce
n'était pas du niveau 1 pour une équipe
qui veut se qualifier qui veut jouer les
32e de finale donc c'est décevant mais
c'est décevant parce qu'elle est dans le
groupe et les joueurs qu'on pêche ou le
jeu aujourd'hui comparé à leur niveau
donc pour préparer des cinq finales
c'est quand même pas bons sur les
derniers matchs contre des équipes qui
ont plus rien à gagner de faire une
prestation défensive aussi faible quoi
je dirais rien justement le rugby est
wilfrid nous allons parler en fin
d'émission avec olivier laval qui nous a
rejoint sur ce plateau le responsable
événements du sky rugby à quelques jours
du tournoi international la cinquième
édition de votre tournée internationale
bonsoir à vous bonsoir à tous mais tout
d'abord nous avons parlé de ce projet
pédagogique qui se déroulent du côté du
lycée saint-vincent-de-paul à versailles
avec patrick guérin vous êtes donc
professeur au lycée saint vincent de
paul et vous avez amené avec vous un
élève de votre classe de seconde
lucas janicot bonsoir à tous les mois
bonsoir alors quand on préparé
l'émission vous me disiez donc que ce
projet était né il ya quelques mois
l'objectif est le principe c'est surtout
donc de récolter de l'argent et en
fonction de cet argent
eh ben vous fait des courses tout
simplement c'est ça c'est eux qui peut
courir
si vous n'êtes là ce soir et que si vous
allez courir c'est parce que vous avez
récolté beaucoup d'argent c'est une
bonne nouvelle
par contre maintenant va falloir courir
il faut que ça alors ça c'est déjà
réalisé récemment puisque j'ai fait le
l'eco-trail
de dimanche dernier qui s'est bien passé
j'ai fait partie des finishers comme on
dit et puis et bien ils ont tellement
vendu mais km que temps je suis obligé
de courir le marathon de paris le 7
avril prochain sur les trails avait
participé à quelques courses et de 80 ou
grands vous avez combien 322e sur les
gens très biens reste que devant 80 km
de course en 9 heures voilà sacrée
expérience des élèves au départ des
élèves à l'arrivée de la famille à
différents rendez vous sur le terrain
et puis plein d'émotion dans les
pensions la dame de fer cette année on
n'est pas montée jusqu'au premier étage
et qui était la tradition dans les
contrats voilà donc l'année prochaine
parce que vous êtes déjà 1,7 pour
l'année prochaine
neuf heures de course hallucinant on
imagine neuf heures de course à gérer
relativement simple en fin de compte
j'ai appris j'ai pris ça un peu pour un
parcours initiatique me suis dit newer
et c'était votre première course en fait
aussi longue
voilà jamais fait formao sinon comme
l'avait fait 67 au lavoir et pas 80
comme ça pas 80 aussi préparer parce
qu'on s'y prépare aussi un entraînement
mais c'est 80 là
je pense que c'est toute ma vie s'est
arrêtée les premiers pas les derniers
j'espère bien le contraire mais je m'en
souviendrai vraiment donc alors vous
courrez parce que vos élèves comme lucas
récolte de l'argent c'est donc un
kilomètre 10 euros si je me trompe pas
c'est comment alors comment vous avez
récolté cet argent dans ce projet
pédagogique lucas est bien pour
commencer c'est est financé par la
classe pour donner des dons ensuite on
est allé voir un peu notre entourage
pour pour leur demander et ils nous ont
donné en fonction de ce qu'ils pouvaient
et c'était quoi la majorité des noms en
moyenne à peu près il y avait des
grosses sommes
un petit peu quand même il était
généreux ça aller jusqu'à 100 euros je
crois en chèque est actuellement menée à
1340 et alors vous n'avez pas eu trop de
mal justement à des marchés vous est
peut-être aller aussi vers des
entreprises où vous avez peut-être aussi
imaginer je sais pas des petits des
petits fonctionnement pour vendre encore
plus là on vers des entreprises où j'ai
effectué mon stage qu'on a fait et alors
quel a été le rôle du professeur dans ce
projet éducatif bas de les tenir
informés moi de mon avancement petit à
petit sur sur l'entraînement de
coordonner un peu tout l'ensemble
d'aller dans leur sens sur les idées
aussi lorsqu'une a plein qui ont
accueilli l'initiative de vendre des
porte-clés par exemple ils ont fait des
porte-clés aller à l'éffigie de petits
chiens puisque le symbole de
l'association c'est dépit labrador qui
qui seront grands et qui ondes aideront
ces non voyants et malvoyants acquérir
leur autonomie
ça a été aussi vis-à-vis des entreprises
partenaires avec le lycée saint vincent
de paul qui ont financé on a une belle
entreprise qui nous a donné 500 euros ça
a été aussi des sommes très modestes
entre une petite récolte en cours de
récréation un euro de 0,3 euro 1 km
quelques 100 m et quitte à petit l'on
construit d'un bout à l'autre
moi je dirais que ils ont eu la partie
la plus gestion et comptable mais voilà
partie physique mais vous l'aimez bien
vrai professeur pour le faire courir
autant ou alors c'est fait exprès comme
ça on est fatigué oui vous en faites
plus encore l'odeur vous marchez
et justement ça motive encore plus quand
on sait que c'est son professeur qui va
courir on se dit qu'on va récolter
encore plus d'argent pour le faire
souffrir en télé mais surtout que c'est
pas commun de pour un professeur de
courir pour une association
et ça vous a attiré le cet aspect
justement de donner de l'argent derrière
à une association qui qui lui tint pour
pour les malgré un chien jeu de
malvoyance a du temps aussi
je pense que tant ils ont appris aussi à
ne plus penser forcément qu'à travers
les outils informatiques telles de
téléphone etc
on y consacre énormément de temps là ils
ont pu réellement aller au delà
consacrer un peu de temps au tour 2 en
données et je pense que c'était
important aussi de pouvoir aller au delà
de ça voilà les élèves sont motivés est
ce que le professeur est encore plus
motivé à courir derrière c'est courir je
partais aussi d'inde ainsi qui s'appelle
qui courent ou pour un orgue et c'est
une communauté de coureurs et il a
beaucoup qui courait pour des
associations et on s'est dit à un moment
donné ce qui est vraiment très
appréciable c'est de courir autrement et
courir autrement passé course pour une
cause et on devient moins centré sur sa
performance mais plus avec l'exigence
des autres derrière et la prochaine
course ce sera donc le marathon paris
exactement toujours aux mêmes profit de
la même association
toujours pareil aliénor associations sur
bordeaux vont aller ramer mentionné pour
récolter des fonds pour un chien
d'aveuglé exactement marathon de paris
ce sera plus facile
en tant que spécialiste 42 km on va dire
qu'il ya c'est moitié moins de distance
est-ce qu'on a presque payante
différemment justement l'effort par
exemple la préparation puisque vous me
disiez que pour le 80 km vous aviez
courir montagne voilà il y avait
beaucoup de préparation derrière tout ça
l'endurance beaucoup d'endurance là le
format du marathon la vitesse est plus
rapide
là on est sûr sur l'éco trail ont été
plutôt sur du 8 km heure là sur le
marathon va être plutôt sur 12 km heure
donc un effort qui va être plus
concentrés plus dense plus cardio on va
dire cardiovasculaires et puis plus
- demont témoin de descente donc
vraiment différent mais plus sollicitant
puisque c'est du bitume donc il ya moins
de répit en termes d'articulation etc
c'est moins simple on va dire - simple
mais bon ça va le faire
merci beaucoup et l'ucad est revenue ce
soir sur notre plateau filles on suivra
les prouesses donc au marathon de paris
xi si tout va bien chez moi juste savoir
si lucas ça t'a donné envie de courir
aussi
alors moi j'ai fait un petit peu de
course à pied je n'avais pas fait
énormément mais 80 km 81 kg mais je
n'aurais pas suivi non il va falloir
s'entraîner à falloir prendre la relève
après le professeur voilà merci de
galles résolution c'est en tout cas
trouvé de rester encore avec nous le 7-8
sport qui se poursuit on parle golfe oui
comme tous les ans le golf national va
accueillir du 4 au 7 juillet le prochain
l'open de france cette compétition où la
crème des joueurs internationaux
viennent swing et du côté saint quentin
en yvelines et pour un événement de
cette envergure le parcours doit être
parfait tout simplement le jour j cette
semaine nous avons d'ailleurs suivi les
coulisses de l'entretien avec patrick
jacques de dixmude
l'open de france se déroule seulement en
juillet mais c'est dès maintenant que le
parcours de l'albatros se met en forme
cette opération d'entretien dit de
carottage se décompose en trois phases
une première machine répond le sable sur
chaque trou du parcours
la seconde étape revient à ce tracteur
armée du carottage ces grands pics perçu
la terre enfin cette voiture verte
faisant office de dameuses infiltre le
sable dans les trous ces petites
trousses on parle est rempli avec les
sables à cana province où il va
permettre les auxiliaires et d aller à
la racine de doha sont en même temps
avec la pluie et ça va augmenter la
capacité des drainages en l'espace d'un
mois trois mille tonnes de sable seront
déversées sur les 150 hectares du
parcours pour cet entretien il faut
absolument des conditions climatiques
sèches
l'objectif obtenir le meilleur fairway
possible pour l'open de france vers le
web pour le mois si on fait un film très
fine c'est un ferry uniforme avec les
mines les mêmes types de races hommes et
pour tous les faits louis avec honda
sonne très fine et qui a les faits il ya
vraiment verticale une vingtaine de
personnes s'affairent à redonner vie aux
féroé évidemment jouer au golf entre les
tracteurs n'est pas idéal pour tout
joueur qui se respecte
alors pendant cette période ils
bénéficient d'une réduction de 10 % sur
le tarif du parcours qu'ils se rassurent
le sable aura disparu d'ici dix à vingt
jours
le golf qui se préparait pour l'instant
nous allons nous intéresser au rugby on
parlait tout à l'heure de plaisir on va
s'intéresser à l'autre club important du
secteur celle 50 ans et demi oui tout à
fait le style rugby pour en parler
d'ailleurs de ce cinquième tournoi
international du club olivier laval le
responsable événements du club bonsoir à
vous alors c'est la cinquième édition
donc on va dire que le tournoi
s'installent petit à petit dans
dans l'environnement justement de cette
période de fin de saison où il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup d'événements de ce
type c'est difficile de s'insérer
justement dans ce milieu là au niveau
des tournois elle n'est jamais difficile
de s'insérer quand on a la volonté avant
tout à l'heure monsieur parle
effectivement d'avoir des objectifs
c'est un objectif fort qui est fixé
depuis cinq ans à l'intérieur de notre
club
objectif qui est effectivement soutenu
par l'ensemble des institutions qui nous
aident tout au long de l'année suivie
par une soixantaine de bénévoles qui
chaque année se pose la question de
savoir quand le week-end de pâques tombe
pour réserver effectivement leur
disponibilité donc la difficulté n'a pas
été grande et à ce jour je peux dire que
nous sommes ravis puisque c'est la
première année première édition nous
faisons ce qu'on appelle un carton plein
ce faire nous avons une possibilité
d'accueil de 48 équipes
les 48 équipes sont cette année présente
représenté par 16 clubs dont trois clubs
européens
deux clubs de province et leur est
constitué de club francilien avec nos
amis proches de la smb de plaisir de
vélizy de montesson et c'est donc pas de
grandes difficultés non bien au
contraire un grand plaisir
quand on prépare l émission on me disait
que morale comme vous venez de le dire
le club le club fait grandir ce tournoi
est ce que vous avez encore envie
justement d'aller plus haut d'aller
chercher d'autres clubs plus importants
il ya le stade français qui vient cette
année mais je sais pas le racing par
exemple ou des clubs comme biarritz dans
le sud ouest alors qu'il faut savoir
c'est que nous avons la chance cette
année effectivement d'avoir le stade
français qui a représenté par deux
écoles de rugby
nous avons eu un tout petit contretemps
puisque vous parliez du racing parce
qu'en fait le racing est fortement
sollicité vu les résultats aussi à ce
jour s'inscrit dans des clubs dans des
tournois pardon internationaux et
nationaux
bien avant notre propre tournoi nous
avons la foule capacité d'accueil en
termes de nombre d' équipe
nous ne pouvons pas aller au delà pour
des raisons de l'adéquation entre les
temps de jeu puisque je rappelle c'est
un tournoi de jeunes donc nous ne
pouvons pas dépasser sur l'ensemble du
tournoi un certain temps de jeu sur les
différentes catégories
en ce qui concerne des clubs
effectivement autres provinciaux nous
avons une politique qui est d'accueillir
des clubs sous forme d'un hébergement
par nos propres familles nos propres
licenciés ce qui nous amène un aspect un
petit peu familial convivial accueillir
des clubs et les accueillir de façon un
petit peu plus d'hébergements collectifs
en dehors de cette structure
ce n'est pas l'esprit que nous en avons
pour l'instant nous avons aussi une
connotation dite internationale ce qui
fait que nous laissons avec notre co
organisateurs un nombre de places
disponibles pour des clubs dits
européens
nous avons la chance cette année d'avoir
des anglais des hollandais des belges
nous aurions aimé avoir des italiens des
allemands
nous avons aussi nous mêmes
malheureusement la confrontation à la
baisse un petit peu des budgets de
certains clubs de la crise européenne
malgré tout quand des clubs viennent de
bernex terme d'imaginer que c'est un
budget qui est raide et placé pendant
voilà ce fortement impactant sur la vie
d'un club
une subvention qui existent justement
pour ce genre de projet qui permet aussi
de faire se rencontrer des jeunes de
différents pays européens
alors nous avons des subventions qui
sont effectivement les subventions de
nos partenaires institutionnels jaillir
connu donc les mairies nous avons une
convention qui est passé avec la casse
qui bien évidemment rsa pour les
subventions un rationnel mais sur l or
nous avons ensuite effectivement
sollicité le conseil général dans le
cadre d'un partenariat sur les aspects
européens qui n'a pas abouti l'an
dernier je vous cache pas que je n'ai
pas travaillé cette année sur cet aspect
là malheureusement on n'a pas travaillé
cet aspect là parce qu'en fait la
délégation et la co-organisation vers
les équipes européennes est complètement
une prestation que nous dédions à une
société qui est sur lyon donc nous ne
sommes pas directement frontale je pense
que pour aller négocier effectivement un
dossier il faut que ce soit purement
associatif l'ass est une prestation vers
une société dont le fondement même et
l'organisation des événements au delà de
notre propre tournoi wilfrid parler de
subventions on s'est souvent que les
tournois bas c'est quand même un budget
important et c'est parfois difficile
d'être à l'équilibré
ça vous concerne cette difficulté
financière et dessus ou voilà alors que
votre compte à ce jour lorsqu'on regarde
l'ensemble du budget prévisionnel d'un
tournoi de cette candeur là on est dans
les 80000 euros y compris les
valorisations sous forme de prestations
mises en place par les mairies et les
instances
à ce jour nous pouvons constater
qu'effectivement depuis quatre ans notre
tournoi bénéficie toujours des mêmes
subventions ne sont pas forcément à la
hausse et c'est donc il nous a été
finalement nous avoir d'avoir un réflexe
pardon d'aller solliciter des
partenaires privés donc ce sont nos
partenaires club durant toute l'année
mais nous avons aussi la chance cette
année d'avoir des prestations
ponctuelles pour ce tournoi notamment
avec un équipementier qui va offrir
l'ensemble des t-shirts aux
organisateurs et notamment surtout aux
500 joueurs qui vont partir avec un
tee-shirt souvenir
on a des prestations qui sont plus sûrs
de la logistique et c'est ce qui nous a
permis effectivement que ce budget soit
bouclé avec un objectif aussi que cette
manifestation soit je suis désolé de le
dire mais rentable et rentable dans le
sens où elle fait vivre le club et nous
permet nous aussi effectivement d'offrir
ensuite à nos licenciés différentes
prestations et sur le plan sportif le
skyrim biais des petites ambitions quand
même on va aller chercher le bouclier ou
pas alors c'est pas des petites
ambitions sont de grandes banques de
grandes ambitions
là aussi on a regardé un petit peu dans
le rétroviseur des années précédentes et
la commission sportive s'est réuni à
l'intérieur du club
et cette année l'orientation
effectivement des moins de 15 ans a été
de regrouper nos deux écoles de rugby
afin de progresser effectivement et de
tirer vers le haut le niveau donc cette
année le bouclier un des trois boucliers
restera sur saint quentin en yvelines à
deux cuillères en bois
pas du tout mais moi donc nous n'avons
pas eu la nappe en bois la france campe
lui rappelle qu'une force de france non
plus d'ailleurs on avait paris sur le
plateau d'ailleurs avec d'autres
d'autres invités qui avaient eu de bons
pronostics merci à vous antonio rappelle
la date du tournoi international de 50
ans c'est ce week-end tout simplement
incendie dimanche de 10 heures à 18
heures sur les terrains à elancourt
stade guy boniface et le marathon et le
marathon aussi en ce qui vous concerne
voilà le 7 avril avec les élèves les
étudiants de votre lycée qui se sont
cotisés ans pour une association et vous
allez courir maintenant alors plus dur
reste à faire
prennent place maintenant aux résultats
pour conclure cette édition du 7 8 sport
le temps d'une petite virgule place au
football tout d'abord en division
d'honneur versailles s'est incliné à
domicile ce week-end 1 but à 0 face à
melun
avec cette défaite les versaillais
sortent du podium et sont désormais
quatrièmes de leur poule de division
d'honneur même sort pour trappe en
promotion d'honneur des faits aussi à
puteaux 2 buts à 0 au final celui en
cours s'est imposé ce week-end dans le
derby face au chesnay les joueurs
détiennent ridet se sont imposées 3 3
buts à 2 et gagne enfin leur premier
match en 2013 une victoire qui leur
donne un peu d'air ils sont désormais
quatrièmes jeux en football féminin
wilfried l'élan corps continue sa
promenade de santé en promotion de ligue
les amazones se sont imposés 4 à 2 aux
racines racines info insisté c'est pas
le racing racing club 13e victoire en 13
journées tous les voyants sont donc au
vert pour les jo dan et l'aigle 14
points d'avancé sur le second clamart
donc ya pas de faute de frappe
c'est bien le racing un peu moins de
réussite en revanche un pour les joueurs
de basket de trappes
c'est toujours le parcours du combattant
un pur trappe en nationale 2 23e journée
et ils se sont encore inclinés malgré un
match très méritants et accrocheur ce
week-end face au 6e manger ils se sont
inclinés d'un tout petit point 82 à 80
ils sont toujours 13e et avant-dernier à
un point du premier non relégable le
mans à trois journées de la fin de la
saison régulière
tout n'est pas perdu chez les femmes en
revanche ça fonctionne toujours aussi
bien 21e journée l'entente le chesnay
versailles s'est imposé en patronne chez
le 4e trégueux victoire 50-8 à 50
elles n'ont pas quitté la première place
de leur poule depuis la première journée
de championnat
on sera à montigny à présent pour
quelques autres résultats du badminton à
8 badminton on n'en parle pas souvent et
pourtant il est une équipe qui se bat
pour le maintien cette saison en
nationale 3 c'est montini ils se sont
imposés lésigny monte 1 à domicile face
au dernier val de reuil cinq matches à 3
au classement montigné d'ailleurs
toujours 4e de cette poule de nationale
3 et avec cette victoire ils prennent
trois points d'avancé sur le 5e marronne
alors le rock est à présent leur hockey
tout à fait les chocs sont totalement
passés à côté de leur match ce week-end
en nationale 3 a littéralement écrasé 15
buts à 2 par le leader camon qui survole
un
ce championnat williams et aulas et
benjamin ferran ont sauvé l'honneur tout
de même déjà assuré de jouer les
playoffs avant ce match lisant leur
courtois va devait avoir sûrement la
tête ailleurs et sûrement aux phases
finales
au classement ils conservent leur
deuxième place de cette poule à de
nationale 3 devant aubergenville qu'ils
rencontreront d'ailleurs lors de la
dernière journée le 31 mars une victoire
qui leur permettrait de s'assurer un
premier match de classement
plus abordable la folie du harlem
tchèque qui se poursuit en attend sur
saint quentin en yvelines quelques 200
étudiants devant la bibliothèque
universitaire ce sera mardi avant de
découvrir le reportage et puis les
images de leur petite création d'autres
images willems et un club de sport une
fois de plus on avait vu la smt rugby
accueille comme vous le disiez l'ailé
club saint quentinois s'y mettent aussi
parce que là c'est le s bi- encore
l'entente sportive de guyancourt qu'ici
mais ils ont mis à profit tout
simplement leur vestiaire c'est l'équipe
senior qui vous montre tout ça
oui
voilà le 7-8 sport qui touche à
sermonner les nerfs les invités ils ont
eu plein d'idées n'hésitez pas
d'ailleurs à commenter ce 7,8 sport sur
les réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag le
7-8 sport ils nous donnaient tous les
résultats de vos clubs bonne soirée
merci anthony c'est la fin de cette
édition nouveau numéro du 7-8 sport le 8
avril jour férié oblige mais nous
reviendrons bien sûr sur l'actualité
sportive tout au long de la semaine dans
les éditions classiques du 7 8 des 18
heures merci de nous avoir suivis les
programmes qui se poursuivent sur télé
fier